(snazzy music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two
lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
- I'm Rhett and I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
It's my turn to share more
about my spiritual journey.
It being the one year anniversary,
or give or take, of each of us sharing
about our spiritual journeys from,
- Yeah.
- Up into being in our early forties.
- Course.
- I'm about
to hit mid forties, man.
- Yeah, yeah you are.
- I think when you hit 44, that's mid.
- Let's just call it 45.
But of course, I assume you
listened to Rhett last week.
If you didn't, I encourage you to do that.
So last week, I, again, I
appreciate you opening up,
and processing how
things are going for you.
At the point of recording this,
that one's not even out yet.
So, I mean, I'm anticipating
lots of response and conversations.
So thanks for being a part of that,
using EarBiscuits.
Yeah, so now it's my turn
to be on the hot seat.
Definitely feeling nerves
associated with this,
because I mean unlike, you said last week,
unlike most podcasts,
we put a lot more forethought into this.
And like either, I mean,
this is a rewarding process.
It's been, I mean, it's been challenging
for me to pull together
what I wanted to say.
We've talked about it some.
I've had conversations
with Christy, as well.
So if you wanna go to
some emotional places
and explore my spiritual journey
as it stands over this
past year, buckle up.
But if you just wanna
hear me talk about my cat,
well I'll just do that next week.
(laughing)
So you can just wait until next week.
But if I'll warn you,
if you're a cat lover,
you might not wanna
listen to that one either.
I don't know.
I don't know, we'll see.
- Well, no, that's, I'm sure they will.
- But that one, you know,
it'll get a little lighter,
but I we'll see where this one goes.
- Well, and before you
get started you know,
I think it's significant
that we get sort of keyed up
before we talk about these things.
And I think there's,
we're not gonna really,
we're not gonna spend any
time really talking about that
or exploring that.
But I do think that it is in the least,
or in part, related to just how
big of a part of our lives
all of this stuff was.
And, you know, and so and
how significant it was.
And I think if you're a
Christian, or a former Christian,
or somewhere in between, you
can probably relate to that,
this being the most
important thing in your life.
And so when you get really open
and vulnerable about it,
it can stir some things
in ways that, talking
about your cat might not.
(laughing)
- I wouldn't call it my cat, but okay.
We'll wait until next week for that.
But yeah, I've journaled down the things
that I wanna share.
And so let's just get into it.
Like I said, a year ago or so,
I shared my story of
spiritual deconstruction
from an evangelical Christian,
to a hopeful agnostic,
is what I called it at the time.
I don't really refer to that label a lot,
but that's, I still think that applies.
And that story, cover my entire life.
You know, there were snapshots
from age 10 and on, right.
But today I'm only covering the last year.
So it's a different thing.
I mean, it's been a crazy year,
and it's been a tough one
for everybody on this planet.
Of course, to varying degrees,
but it's been a crazy year.
And over this past year, I was blindsided
by a number of difficult
challenges that I would have,
as an evangelical Christian,
have labeled as test of faith.
Meaning something happens in your life,
and your response to it reveals
what you truly and deeply believe.
I didn't think of the things
that I'm gonna share today
in that way as they were happening.
And I think that's kind of
part of what I wanna share
and how I did process those things.
But, you know, in kind of
a compare and contrast,
I realized that's how my former self
would see the things I went through
as test of faith.
To put it even more
specifically, in the past,
as a Christian, I shuddered at the thought
of facing suffering, facing
fear, and facing loss
without the peace that accompanied
a very specific believe about Jesus.
- I think that something that
a lot of people can relate to.
I know for me, when you
think about the potential
of not having God in your
life in the same way,
or not having that
relationship with Jesus,
in the way that you said
you did in the past,
you're like, even in transition,
I know you talked to me a lot about this.
As we were sort of transitioning,
there was this fear of is
something horrible gonna happen,
and I won't be able to make it through,
because I've always had this idea
that you'd retreat
into sort of, you have
refuge in the Lord, you know,
as you're going through those things.
- And that is what we,
that was our practice.
And that was our experience.
And that is where we
found a source of strength
in our relationships with Christ.
So, you know, having that be
a defining aspect of any test
I faced in my life, yeah, it was,
I shuddered at the thought
of that that being gone.
Yet here I was, over this past year
facing suffering, facing
fear, facing loss,
after having moved on from that faith.
- And that's what really
keeps a lot of people
from walking away, frankly.
- So I just wanna share three experiences
from this past year.
But before I do that,
I just wanna go ahead and say that,
I'm in a really good place
right now, spiritually.
I don't look back on, on my
former life as an evangelical,
and wish that I was still there.
You know, if you think, if you go back
and listen to my story,
there's lots of things
that you know, that I
appreciate and that I value
from that experience.
It's by no means all negative.
And I've, you know I
already talked about that.
But I, you know as I go
through these things,
I just don't, you know,
I just kinda wanna head off at the pass
that like, "Oh, I feel sorry for you."
And, you know, I don't wanna elicit pity,
because that's not my point at all.
I'm gonna be very honest about
how I process these things
and the emotional
component and all of that.
But I think it's the fact that you know,
I found a way forward that
alleviated those fears
that my former self had.
So yeah, I don't look
back and wish I was there.
I'm happy, but I am also restless.
I don't know if that's
exactly the right word,
because I mean it in only a good way.
But I'm restless in the sense
that I'd like to think that my spirit,
or whatever you wanna
call it within myself,
is staying open to where I'm headed.
Even though that ultimate
destination is unknown to me.
(chuckles)
But I'm doing my best,
to be honest with myself,
and honest with those that love me,
and honest right now with you listening.
And I feel hopeful, and I'm
at peace with my direction.
And today is another day
on that journey for me.
And a big component of that,
is it being an active,
spiritual journey, that I'm on.
And I'm grateful to be doing
this particular podcast
to kind of put another
stake in the ground to say,
a year later, this is
how I'm processing it.
And this is where I'm at but it's, I mean,
I'm sure this will get
heavy, but it's overall,
I just wanted to, you
know, I wanna bookend it
with this message that is
a positive message for me,
that I'm in a good place.
- And I'm glad you're saying that,
because, you know I think that,
as you contrast the way that we approach
these kinds of things, right,
and the way that we approached
our original stories,
and the way I'm sure we're gonna approach
the sort of the follow-up,
is you kind of explore things
through your personal
experience and story.
And you're also a verbal processor.
You also, you know, you aren't
quite as sure of yourself,
and that's, I mean,
I think that is a positive
thing for you, ultimately.
I can be a little too confident,
and a little too sure in
the things that I'm saying,
and a lot of times it'll
just piss people off.
But sometimes when you're being
very vulnerable and honest
about where you're at, and
the fact that you know,
you're just being honest
in your uncertainty.
I think a lot of people are sort of like,
"Oh, poor Link."
And that's not at all what
you've meant to communicate.
And so I'm glad you're
saying that up front,
because I know you, and I know
where you're at spiritually,
and I know that it's not
a place to be pitied.
- Absolutely not.
That's exactly what I'm trying to get at.
And I think that when you mention,
you know my style you know,
it's not as assertive,
and maybe when it comes to certain things
I don't assert confidence in
certain things that I believe,
especially when, what I'm asserting
is embracing uncertainty.
But I also think that
a little bit of that,
well I don't know how much of it,
but a factor that kinda drives that in me
is kind of reacting to,
I just have a negative reaction
to when people assert something
that I just don't believe you
can know with 100% certainty,
it bothers me.
So it's not my instinct to do that.
You know, I share my experience,
draw your own conclusions.
Or just, you know another
thing I'm learning
is that you can truly listen to somebody,
you can truly empathize with somebody.
And it's not always
about making a decision
or a judgment about them.
That's something that I realized
that I thought, for some reason
I thought I had to operate that way.
- Well, that's the
world that we come from.
When you're in a system,
when you encounter things,
you have to file them into your system.
And so we've kind of been
trained for a lifetime,
of systematizing people into an ideology,
and we're trying really hard
to not continue to so that.
- There's a way to be
impacted by empathetically,
interacting with somebody that's not,
that judgment doesn't have
to be a component of it.
And you know, which brings
me to the fact that like,
a year later, yeah, I
don't have any more answers
than I had a year ago. (chuckles)
But I'll tell you, I
do believe that my soul
is richer because I've made some progress,
in knowing, and loving myself more.
And that's through therapy,
through introspection,
through conversations.
And I'm beginning to experience,
how understanding and accepting myself
has expanded my capacity
to love other people.
That's where I felt like I've needed
to focus a lot of my
energy for the past year,
in terms of my spiritual journey.
And, you know, I feel like,
for Christy and I, as a couple,
just to kind of talk about the
two of us for a little bit.
This journey is really stretching us.
And I mean, really good stretching
is really not comfortable. (chuckles)
You know, sometimes it hurts a little,
it needs to hurt in the right way,
so that ultimately it's strengthening,
and definitely the experiences
that we're going through together,
and the spiritual
components of that included
are strengthening our bond.
So, we're good on that
front too. (chuckles)
Christy really helped me figure out
what I wanted to say today.
And, you know, as I was
kind of prepping it,
you know, I texted her yesterday,
and I sent something to her,
and I just also told
her how much I love us.
And she replied and said, "I love us too.
I want you to feel freedom
and embrace this journey
that you are on."
Heart emoji.
And it meant so much you
know, to have her support,
and to say, "Be free, embrace
what you're going through."
You know, it's not, you're
not a victim of something.
You know this is a journey to be embraced,
to be celebrated and you know,
but I'm just so grateful that she can,
she loves me in that
way, and that she can,
she can send me that text, you know.
I don't think I'd be able
to share these things
publicly right now, without her support.
I know I wouldn't.
And people also wonder about
our kids in this process.
So, you know, I wanna talk about that
just a little bit too.
Honestly, I mean, there are times
when the fear creeps back in
that maybe we've done them a disservice,
by not raising them in the church.
But I don't believe that,
because I see them, I know their hearts.
I mean, while there may be
things they missed out on,
there are many pitfalls, they were spared.
And you know, I look at
Lily, I look at Lincoln,
I look at Lando, and I know them.
You know, they're
wholehearted, wonderful humans.
And I admire them so
much for who they are.
And I'm proud of them.
And I don't regret the,
I don't regret the
trajectory of our lives,
and you know, how we parented them.
And I stand by it overall.
You know, I'm very flawed.
And, but I think it's important
that they could articulate those flaws.
- Well, I know, I think,
one of the things that
both of us have encountered
post-deconstruction as a dad,
is within the church, within
the evangelical church,
there is an expectation
that the dad, the father,
is the spiritual leader of the household.
- Yeah.
Based on a lot of things,
mostly just patriarchy.
But, and there's an expectation
that not only would the dad be a leader,
but the dad has the answers.
- Right.
- Right, and the dad sets
the tone, sets the pace,
he leads his family.
And I mean-
- And he's held accountable to that.
- Well, but also as a Christian man,
as Christian dad, there's this expectation
that you'll have the answers,
and that there's very few things
that you won't have answers to.
And there is a playbook for everything
that your kids, or your
wife might encounter.
First of all, a lot of pressure.
But I think in my case,
there was a lot of sort of
just playing along with that,
being like I don't really
have the answers to this,
but I can point you to an answer
that we sort of collectively
as a community come up with.
And I think one of the
biggest things as a father,
is when there is true uncertainty,
there are situations that
do not have an answer,
and being able to say, "I don't know."
I don't know if there's
a satisfactory answer
to this question that you have.
I don't know if there's
a satisfactory solution
to this situation, but we
can figure it out together.
And that's, if you've had something,
if you had a system, and you
no longer have the system,
you can feel that fear
that you're talking about.
It's like, man, they're
going through this right now.
And if I just, I'm not
sure it's the right answer,
but it is an answer
that I could be getting
from my former belief system.
And now I'm just saying, "I don't know."
And you feel a little bit,
you feel like a failure a little bit.
- Yeah, I mean, Lilly's turning 18,
she's leaving the house,
go off to college,
and you know being adult.
But, and you know everything
I said a few seconds ago
still stands, but I have
noticed that there's times
when I would not, I think I
would opt to not say something
because it would be,
the instinct is in the lack of an answer,
it's hard to make something
a teachable moment when
what you're conveying
is embracing uncertainty
and the truth of that.
And it's, you know, I think
some things will come clear
as I continue talking about-
- It would come true too. (laughing)
- Come true. (laughing)
As I, you know, will come clear about,
what I continue to
wrestle with from my past,
and how it impacts my
point of view on myself
and my relationships with
Christy and the kids,
and other people.
But, you know, I'm trying
to take a more active effort
to have conversations,
open-ended conversations
where these topics are not taboo,
just because you don't have an answer
doesn't make it taboo.
It doesn't make you
something to be ashamed of.
You know, it's like, this is real,
and let's not be afraid
to talk about it openly,
as a family.
So I mean, just to complete that point,
when I look at my
relationship with myself,
my relationship with
Christy and with our kids,
I am so grateful for what we have,
and I'm relieved, (chuckles) honestly.
Because like we said, there was a time,
for most of my life, in fact,
when I firmly believed
that those relationships
could not flourish and weather
life storms apart from Jesus.
So, you know, with all
that we shared last year,
and I still struggle with
giving myself permission
to outright say this,
but if there is no God,
I'm okay with that.
In fact, I'm even good with that.
I'm not sayin' I prefer that,
but I'm sayin' I'm even good with it.
I have accepted that
as a real possibility,
and I think I'm at peace with it.
Maybe there's a loving God,
and I'm open and hopeful that there is,
but I'm also good if I never find out.
Because there's just no
guarantee that I will find out.
In the meantime part of
my spiritual practice
is processing and shedding,
the guilt and baggage of judgment
that I've carried for
the majority of my life.
Maybe my point of view on
these things that I've stated,
you know maybe they sound
like harsh statements.
I think about people who love me
who would hear me say
those things and I'm like,
"Well, maybe I could have
taken the edge off of that."
And maybe my perspective
will change over time,
but that's where I'm at,
I don't wanna be embarrassed
or ashamed of it.
Or like I said,
I wanna shed the guilt
and baggage of judgment
that comes along with
me saying that out loud
to who knows how many people.
I mean that's just a big part
of my personal work right now,
because I mean, at 42,
I hopefully have even more life to live,
then I've already lived.
- Ah, so at least 84.
- Yeah, I'm aimin' for 85. (chuckles)
- Well, that was, I mean, I don't know,
that would be currently beyond
the average life expectancy
of an American male.
- Keep that to yourself.
- But I have to believe that that'll keep,
I think it's actually
has reversed recently.
And livin' in California and
breathing in all this smog,
you're probably not doing yourself,
I'm just sayin', ah you'll
be lucky to get to 84.
- Well, okay.
Given that it seems that
half of my life is over,
I'm gonna live the life that I have,
and I'm wanna embrace it wholeheartedly.
You know, I wanna move forward
embracing the now that I have been gifted.
- Yeah.
- And I can say that I've been gifted,
even though I don't know
even if there's a giver,
but I hope there is. (chuckles)
So I'm ready to share
some of my experiences,
three of them over the past year
that have helped define what
my spiritual journey looks like
up to this point.
Like I said, you know, for me to say
it's been a difficult year.
You know, I can keep acknowledging
how people have it more difficult,
or how it's been a difficult
year for so many people,
but you know, just, it has
been a long and difficult year.
And there was a pretty lengthy buildup
to my nanny passing away.
You know, I mentioned that
as one of my most meaningful
moments of last year.
Of course that's my mom's mom.
And she had a sense that
her life was winding down.
So I was the one to help
her get her will in order.
And it wasn't just one conversation,
you know it's like the whole process,
including getting her
to a lawyer and talking.
Everything that went along with it,
it's just a number of months, you know.
And it's all happening over the phone.
And, (deep sighing) you know,
she loved me her whole life.
And in the end I just couldn't
be there, to just hug her.
And, you know, it's so
much of our communication
was just about me helping her find peace
with this outlying thing
associated with her will,
which I, you know I was very glad to do.
But it's, you know,
it's I felt frustrated,
and I felt helpless, and I felt sad.
You know, it's just, you find yourself,
it's different when you're
just having a phone call
and you find yourself having,
"Oh, this is the last phone call."
You know, I'm saying something to her
that is different
because you're not there.
And then you're not there
for the family afterward.
I mean, it was tough you know.
And you know of course I wanted to hope
that she was in heaven.
All of me believes there is no hell,
but a big part of me believes
that there might not be a heaven either.
We just cease to exist.
But I mean that's, you know okay.
That's what I, hold that thought,
I hold that belief in my mind,
but it gets difficult to wrestle with
when you've got one more loved
one on the other side, right.
But, it didn't change the
conclusions I've already come to.
You know, I think of a fear of death,
and a desire for eternal life
for my loved ones, and
myself is very appealing,
but it's not, you know
that's not the foundation
for what I believe.
It's like a benefit, I felt like.
So, it's I don't know-
- Although it might be the foundation
for religion in general.
- Hm.
- Just.
- It just didn't change my conclusions.
I didn't find myself as I was hurting,
and I was wrestling with that,
or I was, you know I
was writing her eulogy,
to give to somebody else to read.
You know, it was all of those feelings.
It didn't lead to doubt, honestly.
It was just you know, of
course she's gonna die.
Of course, we're all gonna die.
It's just, you know, it was kind of this,
I have these conclusions,
and I have this pain,
and I'm aware that these
things will happen. (chuckles)
So...
I'm left with I don't know, you know.
Do I know, can I assert where she is?
Can I give that comfort?
Can I comfort myself or
my loved ones in that way?
I don't know, who really does?
So I celebrated her
life as much as I could.
And I talked to my family and processed it
as much as I could.
And I tried to embrace the grief
to make it as real as
possible without being there.
And accept something we all know,
that death is a part of life.
And that this is a part
of my spiritual exercise.
I couldn't have predicted,
beforehand that that's how
I would have interacted
with all of it.
And, you know, there'll be another way
when I eventually do get to go home,
and, you know help get
everything in order,
that's still around at
the house and stuff,
I'm sure there'll be
another wave of this, but.
- Well, the fact is is that you, again,
whatever you can say in a
eulogy about your grandmother
that doesn't come from a place
rooted in Christian faith,
is not going to be as
emotionally satisfying.
Uncertainty is not as
emotionally satisfying
as this certain hope
that where you can tell everybody there,
"Hey she's in a better place."
Like, let's just be honest.
That is the easiest thing to say, right?
That is the easiest, most
comforting thing to say
to a group of grieving people,
is that this person is in a better place.
- I do think that they're,
and, you know, I'm still
thinking a lot about this.
There's in terms of, you know,
my relationship with death.
And I do think that
there is, I do have hope
that there's more, there's
a way to embrace it,
and not shy away from
it to find beauty in it,
that is different.
That's not something that
I'm at a place to present,
but it's something that
I guess maybe ironically,
I'm hopeful about.
- Well, I don't think
culturally, or as a species
we're there yet, honestly, right?
- Culturally as-
- Meaning that the cultural convention
of a faith-based funeral
is still the standard
even for people who
aren't really faith-based
in a lot of ways, right?
It's another conversation. (snickers)
- I guess, to move on
to another experience.
I alluded to this as well,
at the end of the year.
But Christy and I walked
through a really difficult time together,
over many months this past year.
And anxiety is not someone's fault.
And it affects more than just the one
who's directly experiencin' it.
It was a tough stretch, pun intended.
There were many sleepless nights,
and there was a lot of fear.
There were times when I
felt completely disoriented,
and again, powerless and scared.
I mean, you know, because you
and Jessie were there for us,
as well as some other close friends.
But throughout all of it,
I didn't really ever think about praying.
Now as an aside, I just wanna acknowledge
that even now as I say that you know,
I think it comes out like
a confession, you know.
It's like, I didn't even
think about praying.
And I'm not saying that I wish I did.
I'm making an observation
and I wanna unpack it.
But like for the second
I'm unpacking my emotions
associated with even saying it,
and the fact that it comes
across as a confession.
I feel ashamed.
I feel shame.
It just wells up from inside of me.
Making that statement, I
feel the feelings of failure,
or being a bad person.
But here's what I believe about that.
I believe that that is
my inner critic talking,
a version of my former self,
and he is not being fair,
or kind, or correct.
If I don't believe in the power of prayer,
why should I feel guilty
about not praying?
And so I, you know, I process that,
and I say, "Come on, just come on Link,
just be free, be free of this."
And I mean, if it were only that easy,
if it was like, incanting
some sort of a spell,
or like something to release this spell,
maybe is a better analogy.
But I mean, you know
this, we talk about it.
Sometimes we joke about it,
which I think is healthy,
but I feel guilty a lot.
It's not really related.
I mean, in this instance,
it's not related to like
specific nitpicky things.
like, Oh, I'm guilty because I did that,
like an OCD fixation
on individual actions.
You know, it's more, I think my guilt
comes from this place of
like a lingering cloud
of guilt that shows up, and hangs around,
and is associated with the overall idea
of me leaving my faith.
It's the pity of my previous
self feeling sorry for me,
and also judging the now me.
But I'm learning that I don't
have to listen to that voice.
So I can say, you know what?
Christy and I walked through
an extremely challenging period of time,
and you know, I didn't pray.
And it wasn't this stubborn,
you know, I've said what I believe,
and now I got to believe
it, and I'm not gonna pray.
You know, there was no
internal dialogue about that.
I just-
- You weren't tempted-
- I wasn't-
- You weren't even tempted to.
- I wasn't wrestling with reverse doubt,
or like, I didn't you know,
like cover my bases.
Like I was at my wits end.
I mean, we were having conversations,
that like I would hear
what I was saying to you,
and it was just, I
didn't know what I meant.
You know I haven't observed,
I haven't been in that situation before.
I don't know that, I mean, you tell me,
have you ever seen me
or Christy at a place
where it was like, I don't know,
and it seems like a different
person like at kind of a loss.
- You were incapacitated.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And, you know, I think that is a moment
where, you know it cinematically speaking
where the character would
drop to their knees and say,
"Oh God, I'm sorry that I forsook you."
You know like a moment of
repentance or something,
or just a moment of
desperate prayer, you know.
Like if, you have the
cinematic bargaining with God.
- Well, and I think that's
because that's the narrative
that we believe, and I think-
- Yeah, it'll cut, you'll hit rock bottom.
- And I think it's what a lot
of people have said about us.
It's just like, okay, well those boys
are riding high right now,
but you know the moment
that the bottom drops out
from one of them, some tragedy happens,
is like that's the moment
that they'll turn around
and come back to God.
And I-
- And I just don't-
- I don't wanna skip over
the inner voice thing,
because I if you're not
gonna come back to it,
because I think that's really significant
for so many people, the former voice.
And especially as somebody who struggles,
with, I don't necessarily, I
struggle with a lot of shame.
I'm the king of shame, but
guilt is not so much my thing.
But for somebody who struggles with guilt,
being a part of a religious system,
especially in our experience,
evangelical Christianity,
it's like steroids for the guilty, right.
It's high octane.
And of course, I understand that like,
I remember being an evangelical,
and saying that like, "Listen,
no, we're all about grace.
It's the Catholics, or the Jews.
They're the ones who are all about works.
And they're the ones who are guilt-ridden,
but we live in the freedom
that comes with a grace-based
relationship with Christ."
And it's like a fun thing to say,
but in reality, there's
still so much pressure,
and there's still so much expectation.
My wife is an expert
at talking about this,
about what it's like
to be somebody with OCD
in the midst of a religious system.
But one of the things that,
so I also do the same thing.
I have that former self
who's constantly judging me.
I think it was one of the reasons
that I can talk about
these things in a way,
that connects with people
who are still in the church,
because I have a really,
really strong connection
with my former self.
But the change in relationship,
and this is something that
has come through therapy.
My therapist has helped me see this,
is that what you're talking about
is looking at that former self,
and saying that former self is wrong.
That former self is being judgmental.
That former self is not being kind.
And I don't have to listen
to that former self.
I think one additional step
that has been really helpful for me
is having sympathy.
- Yes, well I would say-
- Or having empathy-
- I would say empathy.
- Having empathy for that former self.
- Well, yeah and absolutely.
And so I'm glad you, you teed that up,
because that is something
that I'm working on.
It's like, okay, I know
that this inner critic,
this inner voice, this
former self, is harsh.
But I don't have to respond that way,
because I can also see
that there's, his motive is to protect me.
It's a part of myself, yes from my past,
but it's still a part of who I am,
that's trying to protect
me from something.
But it's like, okay, you know what?
I appreciate what you're
trying to do here.
And I know you're just trying
to help me and protect me.
And, you know, there
is work for me to say,
okay protect me from what,
and let's get into those specifics.
But to have an empathetic response,
that's like, what you know what?
Thank you, but I don't have
to take action on this,
and you are not all of me.
So yeah, that is something
that in therapy, I'm seeing.
And I might hit on it a little bit,
more with this third experience.
But yeah, you're exactly right,
and I'm glad you brought that up.
So just to get back to the trial,
or however you wanna put it,
like what Christy and I went through.
And I mean, I don't wanna,
I'm not gonna share all the
details of it at this point.
I think, you know, a lot of
that's her story to tell,
and it's, or maybe our story
to tell together at some point.
Who knows, but for now,
you know I'll just say
that it was, Christy who was dealing
with a debilitating level of anxiety,
you know with all the
circumstances that are happening.
Like a certain level of health anxiety
that then just became, yeah,
it just became debilitating.
And there were panic attacks,
and there was, you know, it's
not as simple as Googling
how to deal with a panic attack,
or how to deal with health anxiety.
You know, it's like you
find yourself in a place
where it's okay.
The natural tendency is
a downward spiral here,
that then we've gotta start,
find the right people to talk to,
and the right things to do,
to back back out of this,
or really, I would say to walk through it,
to a healthier place.
But as far as it relates
to my spiritual journey,
just kind of processing
how I did respond to it.
Yeah, I didn't pray to, or curse God.
I just, I mean, I just
responded practically.
You know, I did everything that I could.
I just, I mean when I look back on it,
I would say that I met
the situation with love.
I felt as if I was acting
on instinct at the time.
But I realize now that it was,
I mean it was simply love.
I love Christy with
everything that I've got.
And it was then that I,
I mean I really knew it
at those points, you know.
And we leaned on friends
and professionals,
to help us, and they did,
and we got through it.
And I mean, it's not,
they're residual effects
and there's some long-term things
that we deal with associated with it,
and that we're more ready for now.
But when the worst of it was behind us,
I was extremely grateful.
But I didn't thank God per se.
I didn't take credit.
And I'll quiet that voice that tells me,
that I should feel guilty
for not giving God the glory, so to speak.
I mean, maybe somebody would
listen to our description
to that inner voice and
say that that's God,
or that's the Holy Spirit.
And, you know, but I don't
know, but I do not think so.
You know, because of the outcome
of what that voice is telling
me, the application of it,
it's just not, that's not it.
- Well, and as someone
who is also married to someone
who has had a lifelong
struggle with anxiety,
in a struggle with anxiety
that has been debilitating at times,
and has happened inside the church,
and, you know, with great faith,
and then outside of the church
with no faith in that system.
There is, in my experience,
there is a tendency to,
because you have the ability to pray.
And because you do have the ability to,
when you're at your wits end,
to sort of give it over to the
Lord, to invite God into it,
sometimes that leads to
excluding or bypassing
the practical steps that
would actually be helpful.
- Yeah, we had to drill in very deeply
and specifically with
professionals involved,
with therapist and psychiatrist
and things that, you know,
there's no embarrassment
associated with saying that.
And in the same way that if
you had a physical condition,
if you had, you know, that
you would drill in medically,
and you would do everything you could,
and you can just resort.
- But there are people.
There are people within the church-
- To only a spiritual exercise.
- Like prayer.
- There are people
within the church.
- Like prayer.
- And we weren't, we don't
come from a tradition
that is like anti-science and anti,
I mean little anti-science,
but not like anti-doctor necessarily.
I mean, it's kind of
becoming more anti-doctor,
with COVID and everything.
But there is this, there
is a little bit of a,
hmm, oh you didn't, God
didn't do this for you.
You kinda had to go to the world
to get your problem solved.
And there's some people,
depending on what tradition they're in,
that are that live in
debilitating mental illness,
because they cannot-
- Specifically-
- Get out of the system.
- Especially mental illness,
because those type of things
are the unseen problems and challenges,
are the ones that can
be easily written off
with a prayer or a proverb,
or you know, some teaching.
And I, you know, having
benefited from therapist,
and psychiatrist, and
psychological treatment,
it's just not the, you know,
it doesn't pinpoint the
specific problems, you know.
I think that it requires
a professional to do that.
It's not just something
that you can apply just
to general platitudes.
- And I'll admit something,
that this probably get me in
trouble, but I'm used to it.
Now, when we seek treatment
from professionals,
whether they be therapist,
psychologist, psychiatrist,
either for ourselves, or for other people
that we know who are going through things.
I actually, at this point in my life,
I try to steer away from people
who have a faith-based approach,
or who really bring a Christian worldview
into their treatment again,
because my experience
is that it's like filling in the gap
with something that isn't
actually going to be helpful.
It's like, let's set that aside.
Let's set that uncertain,
I don't know if praying does anything,
giving it to God may do nothing.
Let's take the practical,
tested approach to this problem
so we can actually solve it.
And again, I'm not saying
that having a Christian
worldview is a bad thing.
I'm just saying when somebody is,
if I've got a cancer
doctor, who's working on me,
I don't want that doctor to say,
"You know what?
I'm doing this operation on you,
but I'm really praying that it goes well."
Or do I just want him to say,
"I'm going to do it well,
and it's all on me to do it well."
Again, I mean-
- I well I don't, yeah.
I'm sure that there's pastors who,
if people come to them
from their congregation
with problems, they'll say,
"With this particular challenge
that you're sharing with me,
you need to see a
psychiatrist, a psychologist,
a therapist, you know."
But that wasn't our experience
when we were growing up.
And you wouldn't even,
even if you had to go
to one of those places,
you would just use, you would
say, I went to counseling.
You would use a code word,
and it would be stigmatized.
And it would be-
- There's like a lotta
prayer-based counseling,
and that kind of thing.
That's acceptable.
You can do that, but if
it's just the practical,
scientific stuff, then
I don't know about that.
That's kind of the attitude that we had.
- So, I'll move to the
third and final experience
that I wanted to share today.
And that's...
and there's, yeah the details of this
are not my story to tell.
So, you know, forgive me for,
or don't forgive me, just
I know you understand
that the way that I'm telling this,
and the details I'm
putting in and leaving out.
My mom is currently facing
what may be the most difficult
trial of her entire life.
Every day, all year long, for years now.
And again, we have the COVID of at all.
I'm her only child.
I don't know if you could
tell I was an only child.
- (snickers) Choke on it.
- And (chuckles) yeah,
and I've not been able to be with her.
And I try my best to get
better at talking on the phone,
and to understand her situation,
and assess what needs to
be done, and to help her.
But I'm stuck on the opposite
coast because of the pandemic.
And so I, you know, I worry about her.
Again, it's that feeling of helplessness,
and, you know, I feel bad for going weeks,
in between talking to her.
But when I do talk to her,
she's always happy to hear my voice,
and she doesn't wanna
dump her problems on me,
but what else is there to talk about,
because this has become
her entire life, you know?
So we talk about how she's doing,
and I try to really hear
her and offer encouragement,
and help think through things.
And it's become, you
know like I just realized
how difficult, and the toll
this was also taking on me, you know.
And we were on the phone recently,
and she relayed a conversation
that she had had with someone else.
And I'm not gonna tell you the story,
because this story was meant for me.
And you know what?
When she told me the
conversations she had,
she didn't build it up,
or maybe she didn't even
realize the poignancy of it.
But again, I'm not sharing,
I don't wanna share her situation.
But what she shared was,
it was heartbreaking,
and it was honest, and it was beautiful,
and it was tragic, and it was inspiring,
and it stopped me dead in my tracks.
And in this moment I realized,
not only was I being there for my mom,
but even with all that
she was going through,
she was also still being there for me.
And the specifics of her story,
and what she went through,
and was telling me about,
it painted this perfect picture of love.
And she showed me a type
of love to aspire to.
And I you know, I've thought
a lot about it since then,
and I've realized
that this is my spiritual practice.
Love will be my guide.
You know, I'm gonna make up
my mind to be introspective,
to not miss moments like
that, as much as I can.
And I will not tear myself
apart from the inside.
I will love myself, and I will
love others as much as I can.
And I will live the life that I have.
And...
that's my spiritual practice.
At a point when, and so I don't know.
I don't know how people will process that,
as glib, or elegant or, you
know (chuckles) whatever.
But for me, you know, when
you boil something down
to something like that,
there's so much better
just to convey that it
actually means to me,
in terms of,
I think part of it is validating
that I still have a spiritual,
I'm still on a spiritual journey.
You know, I'm not defined
by what I'm not anymore.
I'm alive, you know, I've got,
and I've this moment,
we're sharing this moment.
And there's so much beauty
that we can enjoy and
appreciate, or we can miss.
And, I'm sure that includes
everything that I've talked about.
Like, I didn't talk about these things
to pull at heartstrings
and just to prove anything.
It was, these things are going to happen.
Who am, I'm not, you know,
tragedy suffering, loss, death.
These are not things that I
want to try my best to avoid.
You know, who am I to expect
for these things not to happen
to me and people that I love?
Things happen.
And giving myself permission to say,
You know what, this is not only my life,
but this is my spiritual practice.
And...
I'm good with it.
I have a level of peace at this point,
and I'm moving forward, hopefully.
- Well, love being your
guide as, you know,
60's, peace, and love, as it sounds,
it is actually very practical,
and actually a lot more informative
than I would have ever thought.
You know, 'cause I-
- I just, yeah.
'Cause I thought
- totally on the same page.
I thought it couldn't be enough.
Like, yeah, I mean, you
say it can be enough, but-
- To navigate a situation,
a life situation
that is a very specific challenge,
kind of like the ones
that you've shared here,
there is sort of the Christian way
to do those things, right?
I would argue that in many ways,
the Christian way is a way of love, right?
You will navigate it in a way of love.
You know it's not a super simple thing.
There's plenty of places where everyone,
within the church, and outside
of the church fails in that.
But only thing that I'm saying
is that going into a
complex life situation
where you don't have the rule book,
the literal rule book of
the Bible to guide you,
and saying "I'm gonna let
love guide me through this."
I think it's actually
really, really effective,
and informative than I would
have ever imagined it being.
- That's what, and I'm saying,
that's what I'm taking
from these experiences.
I mean, that's my takeaway,
is that like, it just, you know, we,
I'm still here.
This is not about me. (quietly laughing)
I mean, we normally end in Ear Biscuit
with a recommendation.
You know, I'm not gonna,
instead of telling you something
to buy or watch, this week.
You know, I just wanted
to acknowledge that,
another thing that's very clear to me,
and as I look back on these experiences
that I could not have made
it through any of those
without the support of people who love me,
my friends, my family.
And so, I mean, maybe it's,
as a result of a spiritual struggle,
maybe it's a result of
some other struggle.
But if you know, I just
wanna encourage you.
If you need help, find someone you trust,
someone who loves you no matter what.
And if it feels like a risk,
take the risk, and ask for help.
You know,
I know that it really needs to be somebody
that you trust, who
loves you no matter what.
We were talking about like,
do we have a specific,
I wish we had a resource
that would connect everybody with somebody
who loves them unconditionally.
And I think that's just, that's
how I feel about it, but-
- That's the extent-
- And we will-
- Of my recommendation.
- We will do some research on that.
What I'll add to that, is that
I know that there are people
listening who are still in the church,
or a religious system of some kind,
and not all, listen, again,
the point of what we
are telling our stories
is not to move people out of the church.
But there are some people in a situation,
and you know that it is unhealthy.
And you know that you shouldn't
be there, but you're alone.
And you know that if you go
talk to anybody in your family,
anybody, who's a close friend.
They're all in, they're all in it.
And you know the kind of
answers you're gonna get,
and you feel stuck, you feel alone.
That's, you know, me and
Link, we had each other.
We had our wives, we had close friends.
We actually you know, had
close Christian friends
who were not judgmental
and we can process,
and we can talk openly about these things,
as we processed all of it.
You may not have that.
But so first of all, just
our hearts go out to you,
because we know that there
are people in that situation.
What we can say is that
there is somebody out there.
There is somebody out there,
that you can connect with,
that you can confide in.
And-
- Don't give up looking.
- Don't give up the search,
don't give up the search.
And don't settle for being in a place
that you know is ultimately
unhealthy for you.
- Thanks for listening.
I'm so grateful that we have
this open-hearted community
of support and,
(soft, mellow music)
lots of love right back at ya'.
#EarBiscuits.
- Let's keep talking.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(snazzy drumming music)
(tones beeping)